[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
بانوراما نستكمل فيها هذا الاسبوع مناقشه
الاتفاقيه الايرانيه السعوديه من زوايا
مختلفه هذا المساء وهذه هي العناوين
ما هو مستقبل الميليشيات التابعه لطهران
بعد اتفاق اعاده العلاقات السعوديه
الايرانيه
كيف تنفذ طهران ما طالب رياض بالحفاظ على
علاقات حسن الجوار
مزدهره تنمو لدينا مصالح فيها لديهم مصالح
الذين مصالح فيها
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لدفع المنطقه
والعالم النمو والازدهار وما هي سبل تحقيق
الرؤيه السعوديه من اجل تحقيق التنميه
والازدهار في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
ونحييكم الى تفاصيل استانفوا عوده
العلاقات السعوديه الايرانيه سيكون له
العديد من الانعكاسات على المشاكل
والقضايا العالقه بين بلدين اهمها دور
اذرع ايران واميليشيتها المنتشره في
المنطقه والتي تفرض سيطرتها عسكريا وامنيا
واجتماعيا على عدد من الدول ممثله تهديدا
عليها وعلى الدول المجاوره لايران عشرات
الميليشيات المنتشره في العراق وسوريا
ولبنان واليمن وغيرها من الدول هذه
الميليشيات تحصل على الدعم المادي
والعسكري والوجستيكي المباشر من طهران في
اليمن استراتيجيه ايران كانت واضحه
ومباشره بالتواغل عبر ميليشيا الحوث
اليمنيه دعم عسكري بنقل عتاد من طهران الى
صنعاء وتوجيه صواريخ ايرانيه نحو اهداف
داخل الاراضي السعوديه عدا عن توجيهات
طهران المستمره لميليشيا الحوفي باستهداف
ناقلات النفط وبتهديد الملاحه الدولي
ميليشيات ايران
ميليشيا حزب الله اللبناني
جماعه الحوثي في اليمن
الميليشيات الايرانيه في العراق كتائب حزب
الله العراقي
عصائب اهل الحلق
منظمه بدر
الميليشيات الايرانيه في سوريا تمتلك
ايران اكثر من 50 ميليشيا مسلحه في سوريا
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من الرياض
محمد العنقري الكاتب الاقتصادي اهلا بك من
الكويت سامي النصف وزير الاعلام سابقا
اهلا بك معالي الوزير وبعد قليل سيلتحق
بنا كذلك من القاهره العميد الدكتور خالد
عكاشه مدير المركز المصري للفكره
والدراسات الاستراتيجيه اهلا بكم ضيوفنا
الكرام الى هذا النقاش واسمحوا لي ان ابدا
من الكويت معكوس سامي استاذ سامي سنبدا
بموضوع الميليشيات في الواقع في اطار
مناقشتنا لكل الزوايا في محاوله لفهم هذه
الاتفاقيه وخاصه
ما الذي ستدعمه هذه الاتفاقيه يقول
مراقبون بان موضوع الميليشيات قد يكون
الموضوع الاكثر حساسيه من بين كل الملفات
المطروحه على الطاوله وهي كلها في الواقع
مواضيع مهمه ومواضيع حساسه وشائكه ولكن
الى اي مدى موضوع الميليشيات قادر ان يحل
او على الاقل ان يبدا في العمل عليه
والتفاوض بخصوصه في مراحل قريبه
اختي الفاضله انا اتصور انه هناك تناسب
عكسي ما بين وجود الميليشيات في اي بلد
واستقرار والسلام وعمليات التنميه اليوم
المملكه تتجه باقصى سرعه نحو المستقبل نحو
الثوره المعلوماتيه نحو التنميه نحو حقبه
ومرحله ما بعد النفط وبالتالي لا يمكن ان
يستقر الحال بين هذه الرؤيه ورؤيه تقوم
على الميليشيات لا يمكن ولا ولا يوجد بلد
به ميليشيات وبه استقرار ولا يوجد بلد به
من الاشيات وبه استثمار وسياحه وغيرها
لانه يختطف قرار الحرب والسلام من الدوله
الى ميليشيات ولا يوجد من يعني يضع امواله
او استثماراته في بلد بهذا الشكل نعلم
ونذكر ونستذكر ان مثلا بلد صغير كلبنان
استعرت به حرب اهليه ل 17 عام بوجود
الميليشيات
لو نظرنا الى الخارطه العربيه سنجد ان
القاسم المشترك بين جميع الدول العربيه او
دول منطقه الشرق الاوسط التي بها حروب هي
العامل المشترك هو الميلشيات سواء
بالصومال سواء بالعراق بسوريا في لبنان
حتى في فلسطين حماس وغيرهم بل الامر كذلك
يمتد الى ليبيا وبالتالي النظره التي
ذكرها سمو الامير محمد بن سلمان بالتحول
بالمنطقه الى اوروبا الجديده للمعلومه هذه
اوروبا الجديده قائمه بين الساحل الغربي
الى الخليج والبحر الاحمر يعني الست دول
خليجيه اليوم هي اقرب الاوروبي لانه رؤيه
سمو الامير يعني تمتد الى باقي دول
المنطقه ومن ثم البحث عن السلام يمر عبر
اضعاف هذه الميليشيات لربما الحاقها
بالدول وان يعني تبسط سياده الدوله
بالعراق وفي سوريا وفي لبنان وفي الصومال
وفي اليمن وغيرهم بل ما هو اكثر من ذلك
هذه الميليشيات لا تحقق شيء لا لايران ولا
للدول التي يعني اصيبت بها لانه من
الناحيه الايرانيه هي استنزاف لثروه تقول
حضرتك وتطرح نقطه تقول بان هذه الميليشيات
لم تحقق شيء بالنسبه لايران بالنسبه لبقيه
الدول موضوع اخر ولكن بالنسبه للايران لم
تحقق لها الهيمنه لم تحقق لها امكانيه ان
يكون لها ملفات للضغط مثلا
يعني لم تحقق شيء من زاويتين الزاويه
الاولى انه هذه الميليشيات والاسلحه
والاموال تاتيها من ايران وايران اولى
والشعب الايراني وايران كنظام وكشعب اولى
بهذه الاموال الامر الثاني ان الدول التي
ابتليت بهذه الميليشيات دمرت وقربت
وبالتالي اصبحت عاله على ايران باكثر منها
سندا لايران وبالتالي احلال السلام بهذه
الدول انا اتصور انه سيجعل هذه الدول
صديقه لايران ودعم لايران لا انا لا ارى
دوله من هذه الدول سواء العراق او او
اليمن او سوريا او لبنان او فلسطين او
غيرها هي دول معاديه لايران هذه الدول لو
استقر الحال بها يعني ستكسب التعامل مع
ايراني والتبادل الاقتصاد صحيح ونحن في
جزء اخر سنتحدث عن موضوع الازدهار ولكن
سيد العنقري هل تضررت ايران من دعمها
واستثمارها في هذه الميليشيات هل اضر بها
الموضوع
على مستوى اقتصادها الداخلي
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لكم الساده
المشاهدين ولضيفه الكريم
يكفي ان نقول ان ايران اليوم تحتاج الى
اكثر من واحد فاصله خمسه ترليون دولار فقط
حتى تقترب من مستوى البنى التحتيه والتقدم
الموجود في دول الخليج فما بالك اذا كانت
ستسبق هذه كلها خسائر اليوم في ايران لا
يوجد ارقام اقتصاديه حقيقيه لان الدوله لا
تقدم ارقام دقيقه ولكن ساعطي معلومات من
داخل
الحديث البرلمانيين الايرانيين هم يقولون
ان البطاله 14% احد البرلمانيين ذكر بانها
55% ما تفسير ذلك تفسير ذلك ان اغلب
الموظفين الايرانيين لم يعد الراتب يكفيهم
الا ايام فاصبحوا يفضلوا العمل الحر
وبالتالي هؤلاء اصبحوا بحكم العاطلين
لانهم اذا لم يعملوا فلن ياكلوا ولذلك
اليوم ايران خسرت الكثير خسرت جواره لا
يمكن لبلد ان تحقق تنميه بدون ان يكون
لديها جوار ومحيط
معه اقتصاديا وثقافيا واجتماعيا ايران
بادرت بالعداء ولا يوجد لديها اساسا مشروع
تنموي هي مشروعها مشروع يعني اديولوجيه
مشروع تصدير ثوره مشروع تخريب وفوضى
واساسا يعني لو اردنا ان ناخذها من زاويه
اخرى صحيح انها خدمت الغرب في عمليه مشروع
الفوضى الخلاقه حتى لو لم يكن بشكل مباشر
ولكنها ايضا خدمتهم بانهم حاصروها فعليا
بالتمدد ونعلم بالسياسه الزياده في التمدد
تؤدي لانكسار من الوسط اليوم ايران مثقله
بالاعباء ولا يمكن ان تتخلى عن ميليشياتها
لانها ستنهار بالتالي ستصبح طهران تدافع
عن اسوارها عند طهران لذلك تنمويا ايران
اليوم متخلفه جدا
بلد فقير بلد منع حتى دعايات الدجاج على
التلفزيون حتى لا يعني يضايقوا الفقراء
الذين لا يستطيعون شرائه وهذا يعني ان
هناك عدد كبير ايضا الاستاذ العنقري برغم
كل ذلك برغم من ان ايران تمثل لها هذه
الميليشيات عبئا ثقيلا ولكنك ترى من وجهه
نظرك بانه مصلحه ايران تتمثل في الابقاء
على
هذه الميليشيات او التعليقك لو سمحت استاذ
سامي في ما يخص هذه النقطه هل تعتقد بانه
مع هذه الاتفاقيه ستبدا ايران بالتفكير
بطريقه مغايره هل قادره فعلا على التخلي
على هذه الميديشيات
انا اتصور قضيه الرقبه هي المهم اما
القدره فنعم يعني ايران عندما توقف دعمها
العسكري والمالي وغيره لهذه الميليشيات
انا اتصور الامر هذا ممكن بل انها لن
تحتاج للدفاع عن انفسها على اسوارها لانه
لن يكون هناك مبرر للدفاع اليوم العالم
باكمله يعني يتجه للسلام وللتعاون
لاستبدال الايديولوجيا بقضايا التعاون
الثنائيه وبالتالي ايران ان رقبت بل ربما
وهذا سؤال هام لربما هذا الترمومتر
الحقيقي لقضيه الاتفاق الذي تم قضيه ارجاع
السفارات بذاتها كما نعلم ان الحروب
البارده واحيانا حتى الساخنه تقوم بوجود
السفارات انما القصد او القضيه او تفاؤل
الناس وتفاؤل دول المنطقه هي بالخطوات
اللاحقه وبالتالي انا اتصور انه اذا كان
هناك تغيير بالمنهج وبالمسار سنرى لربما
ضعف لهذه
وانضمامها بالنهايه الى الدوله
ولسياده الدوله لا بديله لهذا الامر
استمرار الميليشيات يعني استمرار الحروب
والتشردم العرقي والديني والطائفي دائما
الميليشيا تمثل مكون واحد من مكونات
المجتمع وبالتالي لا يمكن المجتمع ان
يستقر بوجود الميليشيات من ثم علينا ان
ننتظر ننتظر ونرى دور هذه المليشيات ان
ضعفت فنحن بالطريق السليم ان بقيت قويه
فنعلم ان الدعم الخفي لازال قائما وهذه
يعني دلاله لا تبشر بالخير لدول المنطقه
الى اي مدى هذه الميليشيات اثقلت فعلا
خزينه ايران هذه الميليشيات مكلفه هذه
الميليشيات متوزعه منتشره عبر دول عده
تستخدمها بين الفينه والاخرى ولكن على
المستوى الاقتصادي الداخلي الايراني على
المستوى المالي هل هذه الميليشيات اثقلت
فعليا الخزينه الايرانيه والى اي مدى
بالتاكيد يعني لو اخذنا
مقياسين التضخم
والمرتفع جدا في ايران لعدم قدره ايران
على زياده الانتاج وعلى الاستثمار في
الداخل وزياده الطاقه الاستيعابيه هذا ادى
الى تضخم كبير وانهيار العمله العمله هي
مراه للاقتصاد اليوم
الريال او الدولار يعادل حوالي اكثر من
400 الف ريال او اكثر من 40 الف تومان
ايراني بالوقت الذي كان قبل عشره سنوات او
اكثر دون العشره الاف فهذا الدليل على ضعف
اقتصادي نتيجه ان الانفاق الكبير هو
للخارج وعلى هذه المشاريع وايضا هناك ايضا
تخفيض في النفقات للميليشيات يعني نذكر ان
حزب الله اعلن قبل فتره
المساعدات للتاتيه من ايران او لعانات
انخفضت الى النصف فهذا دليل ان ايران
تعاني ولا يمكن ان تكون ايران يعني بعيده
الضرر الاقتصادي لاننا كما ذكرنا كل
الاموال توجه لمشاريع غير انتاجيه
وبالتالي دفع هذا الشارع الايراني
للاحتجاج بين فتره واخرى هي هو احتجاج
فقراء يعني وثوره قد تكون ثوره بشكل اكبر
في الفتره القادمه ان لم تحل ايران
مشاكلها وتغير من نمط سلوكها وتعترف بان
مشروعها فشل ولابد ان تغير البوصله فيه
استاذ سامي حضرتك من المؤيدين لفكره بان
ايران قادره ان تتخلى عن هذه الميليشيات
وقدر ان تفكر بطريقه اخرى لمصلحتها الخاصه
اولا بالداخل ولمصلحتها كذلك مع جيرانها
ولكن سؤال مطروح ما مستقبل هذه الميليشيات
بحسب قراءتك ميليشيات صرفت عليها كلفتها
تعبت دربت كيف سيكون مستقبل هات
الميليشيات ان فكرت ايران في التخلي عنها
يعني اختي الفاضله خلينا نفكر بطريقه
مختلفه ماذا لو لم تتخلى ايران عن هذه
الميليشيات هل يعني هذا ان ايران ستبقى
تستنزف ثرواتها واموالها كما ذكر الدكتور
اخي محمد العنقري انه واضح المصاعب
الاقتصاديه الحقيقيه التي تمر بها ايران
ودلالتها وانعكاساتها بسعر العمله حتى
الدول التي تداخلت بشانها اليوم اصبحت
دولار ميه الف ليره لبنانيه يعني عشره
دولار يعادلوا مليون ليره وبالتالي لا
يمكن لهذا الحال ان يستمر ومن ثم القضيه
لربما بها خيار واحد فقط هو التخلي عن هذه
الميليشيات محاوله التحول الى نهج الدوله
الحديثه تكون السياده بها للدوله شباب هذه
الميليشيات بدلا من ان يحملوا البندقيه
اللي لا يمكن لها الا ان تدمر وتسفك
الدماء تتحول هذه او يتحول الشباب الى
قضايا التدرب والتعلم وال لا يمكن لهذه
الدول ان تستمر هذه الدول هي حاله على
ايران ولا يمكن لايران ان يعني كان يقال
بزمن بعيد ان صعوبه ان تقوم الولايات
المتحده بحربين بشكل متوازي ونحن نتكلم عن
اقتصاد بحجم الولايات المتحده اليوم ايران
تقوم بحروب على خمس جبهات او اكثر منها
حتى الجبهه الداخليه وبالتالي الكلفه ضخمه
والمورد التي تاتي منه الاموال هو النفط
الناضب الان 2050 كما قيل هو قضيه الزيرو
ميشن وقبلها بعشر وخمسه عشر سنه سيقل
للطلب على النفط وهذا امر طبيعي وستنخفض
قيمه هذه الثروه الناضبه يعني ستسائل
الشعوب قياداتها ماذا فعلتم بهذه الثروه
هذا الامر والمبرر الاكبر اللي يخلي
السعوديه تندفع بالشكل اللي نراه نحو
التصنيع والسياحه والاستثمار وكل
المتغيرات الكبرى في المملكه والحال
بالدول الخليجيه لنراها انا اعتقد انه
ايران يعني لا يوجد خيار اخر بل ربما اختم
بقضيه يعني واضحه جدا ايران لا اشكال
لديها بالمنطقه كحال اشكال الدول
الاوروبيه بعضها البعض نعلم ان مثلا فرنسا
والمانيا والمانيا وبريطانيا كانت بهم
بينهم دماء يعني دمار لسنه وحروب عالميه
ما في هذا الامر موجود الامر هذا غير
موجود بالمنطقه وبالتالي ما في اثارات
مثلا لدى الشعب الايراني من دول المنطقه
والعكس صحيح لا توجد دوله تشعر انه والله
ايران معاديه لها وشعب الايراني معادي لها
او انه والله اتى بالسابق او عبر التاريخ
احتلال ايراني وغيرها الامور هذه غير
قائمه انما كان هناك شق الايدولوجيا واضر
بايران ضرر كبير واضر بدول المنطقه واعتقد
انه التحرك السعودي وقضيه تفعيل الدور
السياسي للصين ومقامت به الصين اعتقد الا
ربما يكون الخطوه الاولى باتجاه الصحيح
وببناء علاقه ون ون علاقه ربح ربح تربح
منها ايران والشعب الايراني والعراق
وسوريا واليمن وبقيه الدول يعني اتصور انه
عدا ذلك ستخرج ايران وستخرج دول كثيره
بالمنطقه من التاريخ العالم لن ينتظر نحن
ضمن ثوره ضخمه ولا اتصور نعم اشاره فرصه
حقيقيه كذلك كما اكد عليها سنتابع في
نقاشنا بعد قليل مجموعه اخرى من النقاط
ومن بين موضوع حسن الجوار وكذلك موضوع
الازدهار وتطور المنطقه التي تسعى هذه
الاتفاقيه لطرحه ولكن بعد فاصل قصير ضيوف
يتفضلوا بالبقا معي